37 de température normale des amis
bienvenue dans cette vidéo
aujourd'hui cette vidéo géniale on est
content avec le mans pourquoi parce qu
on est dans une clinique vétérinaire le
métier que tous les petits enfants
rêvent de faire entre 4 et 8 ans au site
a voulu admettons jour je vous le ton
pied ah c'est pas pareil désolé j'ai un
ami qui s'appelle docteur michael
o'keeffe savez je fais un long week end
du stylet mais ça fait vraiment michael
en français j'ai la chance parce que
cette âme il détient plusieurs cliniques
vétérinaires sur paris je suis passé
loire plusieurs fois dans ses cliniques
pour boire un café avec lui parler et
tout est en fait à chaque fois que je
passais espaces et des trucs dans la
clinique des trucs typique de veto que
je trouvais incroyable je vais donc
demander si c'était possible un jour de
passer vraiment 24 heures dans sa
clinique avec lui avec une blouse de
vétérinaire comme lui ok avec son petit
logo c'est mignon projet 3 de voir tout
ça alors ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
enfile cette blouse qui apparaît trop
grande pour moi
d'après marca au bras suite vous ce week
end on a un petit cédric un bon michael
est actuellement en consultation
du coup en attendant je pas trop quoi
faire je pense je vais pratiquer un peu
avec son instrument c'est pas grand
chose ça c'est la petite troupe sont les
fils un doliprane 1000 et ça ira mieux
mais qu'à mickaël hay voulait il est
beau il est très beau lui dit pas après
les complexes bienvenue de terrain 40e
en garde tu très content d'être là
aujourd'hui
tu fais ça depuis combien de temps un
peu plus de 15 ans à moi il est une
année de plus d'expérience que nous ça
passe en vrille
pas mal j'ai un peu un truc de ouf fait
une offre mais c'est trop bien je te
suis vas-y
on sent le bon sens l'animal a certes
compliqué genre lamont par son fils aux
jsa exactions affecter les uns se tient
à
ouais pour essuyer le les échos avance
de 100 de nos mains de quelqu'un alors
otage il ya pas deux mais il n'a pas de
merde c'est mon jour de chance
michael je sais que tu voulais me
visiter et tu as raison j'ai une tête à
être visitée bien mais il n'a pas chier
dire que je suis bien
merci mon pote tu l'entends legs
il a dit proche la cac a cédé à une
première consultation
on va voir ce qu'il faut faire
m
j'ai encore fait ses petites chaînes de
11 ans ok je suis depuis pas mal de
temps pour un fan de x 22 x une hépatite
chronique et elle allait super bien
ouais sauf que non elle est passée par
là ouais elle a dû manger un peu
n'importe quoi une assiette
elle a repéré bon c'est ce que c'est
béchir et du coup d'arrêt avec du sang
depuis ce matin juste matin c'est ça du
coup on prend pas de risque on contrôle
le foire en effet un petit pression est
donc ses invités ce soir pourquoi une
fois ok c'est un lâche
je suis prêt mais c'est pas toi qui
préférait ouais moi je suis prêt à
nettoyer le gars c'est à dire comme ça
je pouvais y aller
cette prise de sang s'est très bien
passé ça peut paraître impressionnant vu
ce que le chien remue un peu mais elle a
été splendide faisait bien faire
événement auquel appellation à ken
doctor mais gagne en expliquer un truc
tous intéressants en fait si la langue
ça c'est parce qu'elle n'a plus de dents
salon n'est plus revenu par les temps
donc elle sort donc en acheter un salon
qui sort ce mois-ci le plus de danser sa
[ __ ] mais c'est trop mignon
comme l a vu dedans juste de seconde
j'entends pas
on a contrôlé que le foie ouais parce
que c'est son problème chronique sont
pas le prenez la première piste c'était
sa course et ça j'avais bien commencé à
contrôler je sais qu'elle imprime deux
fois et la diarrhée
ça peut être secondaire à ça ok sauf que
là c'est parfait ok elle va être content
c'est vrai au [ __ ] on vous fait un
cadeau
alors il roule une pelle ex à l'anglais
l'incroyable j'avais dit je lui fais un
bisou séjour
ces chaussettes et cherokee on peut
constater l'absence totale de kaka de
sel cheyrou quitter mon gars sûr je
soupçonne très fortement de regarder mes
vidéos en cachette et de kiffer je pense
vraiment vraiment keith abonnés
est-ce que ce chien fait ma taille oui
bon on est sur une chienne qui est assez
vieille qui est soufflé depuis ce matin
elle a pas l'air bien elle a pas l'air
bien parce le souffle et tulle a touché
un peu et tu n'as pas l'impression que
ça vienne du coeur ok généralement sa
venue quand ils sont vieux sur les
grands joueurs qui fatigue c'est le
coeur qui fatigue et puis surtout que
c'est un gros chien et les grands chiens
font quand même très souvent des
pathologies cardiaques
sauf que là j'ai quand même l'impression
qu'elle invente à dont il ya quelque
chose dans le ventre qui à chaque heure
qui a dû dit qu'il me rends compte si
c'est ça il va falloir qu'on aille
vérifier en écho au xi à du liquide il
va falloir contre fonctionnent les
grands chiens font des cancers de la
rate assez fréquent d'accord et ça peut
saigner et du coup elles freinées manger
à terre
ok donc là pour toi là le premier tout
cas faire c'est l'écho pour voir ce
qu'il ya dedans coexistent qu'est ce qui
se passe là dedans et ballon c'est ça
qui nous fait ce métier c'est que tu as
un animal qui va devoir soigner et il
peut pas parler pas de dire ouais j'ai
mal là je me sens pas très bien j'ai
donc du coup il ya tout un protocole à
suivre pour essayer de comprendre ce
qu'elle a et trouver ce qui va pas et
c'est ça qui est dur quoi passer de la
recherche tout le temps tout en tout
temps bon michael ce avec un point qui
fait ça donc il est très bon donc ça va
être très intéressant de sucre sur ça
mais moi par exemple je serai pas par où
commencer quoi vraiment c'est c'est dur
faire une économie jet de raser le
ventre pourquoi qui les poils entre
l'appareil et le ventre donc c'est quand
poil là ton partir
on
m
amis apparemment le coeur est un peu
fatigué les vieilles c'est normal comme
un humain maintenant lui michael veut
checker si les poumons vont bien et pour
ça on va faire une radio je prie ça me
fait trop mal au coeur ce monsieur tu as
vu il aime trop sa chienne il appelle ma
fille comme moi natsu j'appelle mon fils
tu as et du coup je couvre entre oscar
sens et j'espère trop que la vie de
cette chaîne vale continuer quoi
on
michael von analyse de salive des bonnes
nouvelles j'ai des bonnes nouvelles on
avait peur et tous deux que ce soir quel
biais c'est lequel elle respire très
vite et bien sûr très vite j'avais
l'impression qu'ils avaient un gros
ventre en fait est que du gras c'est
bien branché moi il n'y a pas de souci
ceci dit elle a quand même à kirk est
très fatigué avec une pathologie kepa
qui est pas clair je suis frustré parce
qu'on a ça clairement une gt prologue
exactement donc il ya plusieurs petites
choses il ya une glande thyroïde qui
marche pas très bien qui peut expliquer
qu'elle soit fatiguée et qu'elle respire
vite il ya un hacker qui fonctionne pas
très bien mais il ya rien de d'évident
qui nous permet elle en mode c'est la
force exactement donc c'est quand même
une mauvaise nuit bien qu'a priori on va
pouvoir la traiter ça que j'entends ça
je suis heureux et c'était très touchant
de parler avec le monsieur hors cac 40 à
paris puis il trop toujours la même on
voyait pendant le coït mais ça chez elle
et je ris à murray trop fait chier qu'on
doit a vu le mans series
mais monsieur est trop mignon mais ça
fait partie du métier qui bondit
aujourd'hui on arrive à faire ça et ça
ça me ferait nouvelle
hier shibao coup c'est assez
les amis bienvenue dans cette deuxième
journée a family fun clinique
vétérinaire attention on avec eva
chirurgiens de la clinique et sam qui
est une un petit chihuahua femelle qui
va se faire des tarterêts les dents
alors un détartrage c'est un truc
basique en vrai en vrai voilà donc ça
peut être impressionnant parce qu'on va
devoir endormir le chien pour pouvoir
avoir une liberté totale avec sa bouche
faire ce qu'on veut qui sera anesthésié
avec une anesthésie in à l'import
d'ailleurs du gaz
exactement ok ça marche moi je veux le
voir avoir des dents très blanches
où
c'est immédiat de ou frais
on
ça c'est des dents qu'ils ne servent
plus c'est cette dent elle ne peut plus
faire sa fonction et puis quand elle
bouge c'est ça veut dire qu'elle ait des
chaussées que ça veut dire voilà donc en
fait elle va devenir vraiment tout
elle est vraiment elle est vraiment déjà
très très attente la racine est déjà
presque désintégrer savent à cicatriser
tout seul est d'ailleurs sans la dans la
gencive elle sera beaucoup plus saine
j'aimerais c'est l'opération la plus
physique du game à tel point que en fait
on n'ouvre pas le corner l'on n'est même
pas en tenue stériliser en fait y'a pas
de risque d'infection pour le chien mais
normalement quand il va au père un
animal pour ne pas qu'elle doit l'ouvrir
pour se payer un chien qui a mangé un
coup il faut pas manger par exemple un
morceau de jouer ou quoi quartier ben là
c'est vraiment tenu stériliser en notre
dr house ça c'est impressionnant
est-ce que ça notre petite fille chevaux
préféré aller dans propre et l'allée
dans from celles qui restent au mais là
ça va
c'est assez blanc vin pas prophète je
crois que c'est le fait d'avoir vu le
tartre avons besoin maintenant ses plans
de ouf on sera jamais aussi blanc que
des dans de petits jeunes chiens dont tu
le réveil après donc là on a mis l'année
saisi à 0-1
on va attendre un petit peu on va
attendre quelques minutes
ok dès qu'il commence à se réveiller tu
retires le voilà exactement où il va
éliminer l'anesthésique on lui a fait
inhalé ok on l'a exhalant ok d'accord
voilà live et il va être dans le gaz un
peu car elle va se réveiller elle aura
les dents tout propre tout c'est vrai
qu'ils font
cheyrou qui a chié docteur michael 6e
mecs tu es génial plus d'amasser nous
allons regarder pause et on s'éclate
excréments au moins on a eu une attitude
est tout doux
on a eu plein d'émotions plein de
bonheur un peu triste est aussi parfois
mais terme étiez malade c'est vraiment
le métier des enfants veulent faire je
sais ce que je voulais faire je suis
très content d'avoir découvert ce que
c'est que ce métier vraiment parce que
même quand tu fais une école et tout en
fait tu sais pas ce qu'est le quotidien
dans l'éternel et on a vraiment été avec
toi quand ces 24 heures creuses et
appris plein de trucs et c'était top
chef un canard tu parles tu accents voit
sa résurrection et la vie au ciel vous a
plu et à bientôt dans une prochaine
au revoir